[Musique]
et cette semaine des rendez vous très
musicaux et oui il va falloir faire un
choix grégory car le week-end débute
très fort si rendez vous dès le vendredi
et cinq sont music hall a ravi les i
villacoublay
c'est un opéra qui vous attend est
l'espace fils noirs et des
clayes-sous-bois un concert classique
sous la conduite de marianne piketty et
à magny les hameaux c'est le jazz le
jazz de gastines malek qui vous
accompagne en appeler lyon sera plutôt
nostalgique et oui parmi ses plus grands
titres
l'école est finie vous les copains les
rois mages encore space à l'icône des
années yéyé en france sheila et sur la
scène du théâtre espace coluche ce
vendredi elle revient cette fois sur
scène accompagné du groupe pop-rock
hashtag pour une réorchestration de ses
plus grands d'yves
tous
deux fils
combien
je vais maintenant
tu me duels mais une balle
et je tombais
[Musique]
peu de musique du monde si oui à
guyancourt cette fois ce sont les
rythmes jamaïcains qui vous attendent
alors il y aura trois groupes et
artistes qui vont se partager la scène
de la batterie route héritage lee job et
gaëlle and roll dodge fellow la soirée
sera placée là sous le signe du partage
de la tradition et de la musique live
[Musique]
en ce 1er mai
là
[Musique]
merci mélanie pour ce coup de coeur et
pour ne rien manquer des rendez vous est
réservé sa place direction kiosque point
est-ce qu y point fr ou votre émission
le 7-8 culture c'est après journal c'est
ça